well hello there reject nation we are
here today to watch some new rock stars
thor love and thunder trailer easter
eggs break down from the man the erik
the voice guys leave a like if you can
especially if you're excited for thor
love and thunder let's get to it already
people subscribe to new rockstars if you
haven't done so already
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown for the
trailer for thor love and thunder which
gets us so lost in chris hemsworth's
eyes like the bluest guys that it's a
bit easy to miss the love and the
thunder which i assume are what thor's
sweet child named her biceps there's so
many cool details hidden in this trailer
so let's punch those tickets to the gun
show and break down their sprain by
frame let's go
what's going on
these hands were once used for battle
now they're about humble tools for peace
i need to figure out
exactly who i am
all right we open on thor sprinting
through the eras of his life and i'm
pretty sure his youngest self is
actually played by one of chris
hemsworth's real life sons the twins
tristan and sasha we're gonna get them
in there
mirrors the journey of forrest gump a
run and rambler who stumbles through war
zones and prize matches and boats until
turning into a bearded
i may not be a smart avenger jane but i
know what loving thunder is now the
second thing is
kirby comics the winged helmet the blue
pants yellow boots the montage is a thor
surrounded by flames representing his
home of asgard being burned by sirte and
ragnarok now the final shot of the
trailer shows thor in the same bird
collar i'm assuming this is new asgard
of tonsburg burning down making this the
second time thor has had to watch an
asgard burn but you know it's not a
place it's a people you know what i
liked about that running montage too
it's like it seems like at one point
that is definitely chris hemsworth who's
running but i feel like they might have
applied some of that captain america
first avenger effect where they slimmed
him down a little bit yeah yeah make him
look like he's earlier in the journey
from these ashes we cut to a symbol of
new beginnings though we're planting a
tree except this is more than a tree
it's the handle of stormbreaker whose
ruins on the blade for storm breaker
remember stormbreaker's handle was made
from the tree branch arm of groot an
infinity war now once that arm was
severed it ceased to be part of groot
thus why it did not dust along with him
and thanos's snap but years ago i
discussed the theory that thor might
replant the handle of stormbreaker to
regrow the yinjoso world's tree after it
burned in ragnarok which might be what
vin diesel was referring to in that 2020
interview with comicbook.com when he
described groot's return in love and
thunder as quote alpha groot of course
there was gardening here called thanos
cool retiring at the end of his conquest
he tilled the soil as he watched the sun
rise on the grateful universe but in
thor's case here i should say suns
because this planet ain't earth as in
the sky behind him is a massive sun and
then two other planets or moons to its
upper left and then a blue glowing
celestial body another light source
behind the tree and then a ringed planet
in the upper right corner and i am
assuming love and thunder will finally
reveal to us the only one of the nine
realms we have yet to see in the mcu all
time home of the light elves not of owl
even though he is canon in marvel comics
lore wow i think that'd be pretty cool
especially because the last time we
really got to hang out with elves in the
thor world elves were not perceived in
the best light that's true justice for
malachi justice for malakith and all the
dark elves out there yes
and they're light counterparts i guess
but it seems like we don't see any elves
on this planet you know he just got up
there all isolated
maybe it's just a him and alf
notice the scar over thor's right eye
that's from when hella sliced out of
zion ragnarok it's come a long way in
healing and now both his eyes are bright
blue definitely bluer than they were
before and his prosthetic right eye has
been replaced since end game perhaps
that could be why he went to alphine
using the light elves magic to heal
himself both physically and based on
this don draper meditation pose here
spiritually as well now the music of
this trailer is guns of rose's sweet
child oh mine which has lyrics
referencing eyes like the bluest skies
and childhood memories where everything
was as fresh as a bright blue sky axel
rose wrote these lyrics for girlfriend
aaron everly daughter of don everly of
the everly brothers
just appeared in a recent promo for
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness multiverse of madness does seem
like a story about parenting love and
thunder a story about being sweet
children of the gods now of course my
favorite cut of this gun's song is the
acapella rendition from step brothers
guys
[Music]
you don't even look good while you're
singing the worst thing i've ever heard
is 1200 a week for voice lessons this is
what i got okay i'm gonna save it with
the solo we must thank agatha harkness
for singing the key lyric for this
trailer pray for the thunder in the rain
and to quietly pass me by i hope adam
scott could one day be in the mcu oh for
some reason his like weird dry
straightforward like seriousness but
also simultaneously hilarious comedy
skills would be absolutely perfect i
don't know where he would fit in
probably an ant-man movie actually would
be a good idea i think a variant of
justin hammer would work yeah one of
them
thor is the god of thunder but he's
literally burying the hatchet praying
not for thunder to empower him but to
pass him by because i think the thunder
of love and thunder is truly going to be
brought by the villain gore the
godbutcher and the sweet child of mine
of the song is actually gore's child and
wife who were killed after he prayed for
the thunder and the rain to pass them by
but those prayers were left unanswered
and i just find it interesting this
trailer in short of guns and roses dark
aggressive shift in the song from the
ballad to the where do we go
where do we go now where do we go now
as if the darkness is still yet to come
enough of me singing let's move on all
right
i'm not showing how thor lost that
weight from endgame not that he needed
to lose it he wears a trucker hat that
reads strongest avenger a callback to
the running joke of him considering
himself the strongest avenger overhulk
and ragnarok voice activation required
strongest avenger access denied welcome
strongest avenger oh what also
the strongest avengers
i'm the strongest avenger okay so this
responsibility falls upon me but my
favorite detail about this hat is the
fact that thor used a sharpie to write
this over a different way that said
something else because it looks like
that hat originally said the mightiest
avengers but he wrote strong over mighty
and they traced over the est in black so
it would look less weird and then he
just screw it and scribbled out the s of
avengers so it would just be only one of
them
we're going to see him make that hat
modeled on vincent d'onofrio's look and
if it's a baby
whoa
i've been trying to place it this whole
time oh thor mighty god of thunder
who is this kid careful kid don't
embarrass him in front of vanessa wait
you know that movie i've never seen that
that is a brilliant easter egg though
that's about the only scene out of
adventures in babysitting i think i've
seen and this was like a long time ago
before we were all like marvel's
obsessive all the time so yeah i've been
sitting here going he reminds me of
somebody and and he finally placed it
for me it's vincent enough that's a
genius easter egg especially with the
fact that vincent d'onofrio himself is
in the marvel cinematic universe that
works on so many levels so thor is doing
the battle ropes with these chains from
a giant skeleton i was wondering if this
could be another one of the knit
valyrian dwarves like a prisoner who was
left to rot after thanos slaughtered
them but that skull has an odd shape to
it not exactly humanoid so this might
just be another god whom gore has killed
and based on his poor guy being left in
chains maybe this is someone gore
tortured at first and thor decides to
trade there
to file this card
blue pants actually looking a lot like
kurt russell in big trouble little china
make it a bit ironic for ego son peter
quill to roll his eyes here actually
looks like thor might have stolen some
of peter quill's clothes and as i
pointed out in a past video the shirt
that he's wearing may depict a geecher
cell connecting the nine realms now
they're saving this planet populated by
these blue-skinned locals i think this
actually might be centauri for the home
world of yondu which would make this oh
interesting one tribe and he's cool so
we learned that one of the past planets
that i love that destroyed was called
century six everyone in century 6 is
going to die now it's spelled a bit
different century versus centauri but in
the thor comics century 6 is part of the
same alpha centauri star system as
century 4. so i'm wondering if gore the
god butcher's hatred of the gods might
have began because he comes from that
century sixth planet that was destroyed
in order to birth the celestial a god a
hatching that killed his wife and child
while he just happened to be off world
which would make him so angry that he
must now kill all the gods of the cosmic
hierarchy and everyone related to them
including asgardians like thor and
valkyrie and sons of celestials like
peter quill and it could be on this
planet centauri 4 where thor and the
guardians learn the story of a nearby
planet named centauri 6 in their system
with one very pissed off soul survivor
this might seem like an odd thing to
mention when we went to the eternals
premiere taiko ytd was there and we were
fortunate enough to stack a quick photo
with the guy but i would do that awkward
thing where every once in a while i'd be
like how's tyga responding to me and as
directors like sam raimi have said that
you know a lot of them don't even need
to watch the mcu in order to keep up or
make the movies i gotta make but
whenever i looked over at taika and just
watching the way he was observing it
seemed like he was doing it for notes in
a way you know you kind of get that
sense or maybe that's just the way he
i've never seen psycho watch anything in
my entire life
so he watches
and i know they planned this [ __ ] way in
a bit so i'm probably way off on that
just a little side tidbit and then we
get this full guardians of the galaxy
charge with teenage groot who's actually
been filling out more there's some more
greenery on his head the nebula mantis
franklin he filled him out
as he did in the guardians volume 2 post
credit scene and then rocket and then i
assumed drax on the far right but no
gamora we should note after the end game
final battle and quill bringing her up
on a screen in that final scene they
still have not found that variant gamora
from 2014 volleyball ended up leaving
behind thor and cork on a planet that
looks like sakara as they pilot the
benatar through that hexagonal universal
neural teleportation network grid if
this is the car i'm super excited that
they're returning here because this
might be where they can meet up with
beta ray build ah yes yes and the way
they frame this shot weird empty space
on the left beside the word just really
looks like the shot was framed for three
characters
it's all three of them
spider-man trailers you'll notice how
korg has a new look some colorful pants
and a belt buckle in the shape of a goat
head i'm wondering if he might now work
at new asgard which is now a tourism
theme park as the herder of thor's goats
so we take a tour of new york
compared to the colony it wasn't in-game
the structures have evolved from the
sleepy town of tonsburg norway to some
taller curved golden structures like the
old asgard had so either they're
starting to truly rebuild what they once
had or they might just be making a
disney version of it to attract tourists
or they might be doing both we see a
flying boat
steal our gold building
by thor's goats these are named this and
that's not even gonna bother trying to
pronounce it but they mean teeth bearer
and teeth grinder in norse mythology
they are thor's companions they pull his
chariot across the sky and they're
wonderful i'm so glad they're in this
movie i thought they were named tooth
natural tooth grinder that's what i have
seen in different translations
corrected us whenever we've said that
maybe the translations vary or maybe you
guys suck at correcting us you don't
know anything about comic books it's our
job to get on camera and act like we
know what we're talking about it's your
job to prove you don't know what you're
talking about guys
so who feels like bigger of an idiot now
on this boat you can see valkyrie in
korg and then up front two others it
looks like thor maybe jane with them
there and i love it there's a neon sign
reading cocktails and dreams which is
the name of the bar that tom cruise
works at at the end of the 1988 movie
cocktail the 80s references are
everywhere and i'm loving it then this
glorious shot of olympus a realm similar
to asgard in the marvel comics but the
home of zeus and aphrodite all the other
greek gods the design is just
breathtaking like asgard the land mass
is suspended in space with impossible
gravity water just spilling in the mist
here from these roman style aqueducts
that snake through all the structures in
the lower left it looks like it's open
space and stars out there so who knows
this could all be suspended inside of
another part of a dead celestial like
nowhere's headless body because the
sword carried by gore in this movie is
the same weapon that in the marvel
comics lore be headed nowhere so this
movie may confirm that history you'll
notice a pink purple streak meteors
through this olympus space maybe thor
and his friends arriving or maybe this
is an attack from gore tycho what tt
embraces his our flag means
pirate ship as a woman swings over to
embrace him looking like the cover of a
romance novel if this is the same
setting as the tree meditation shot
earlier this might be a light elf of
alpheim notice how the ship behind him
is being smothered by a kraken oh cool
could it just be it's its own its own
thing yeah maybe then like it's just
never this planet that i thought was
earth but if you look closely at the
surface it looks like it might be in the
process of freezing over thought it was
just the sunrise light hitting the
clouds but it does look like it's
streaking through its atmosphere faster
than the planet is rotating toward its
sun thor stands yeah that's what i was
thinking
i i know it's astronomy it has the
powers of the bifrost this is how
they're traveling through these
wormholes in space then lightning
streams through the hall of olympus all
this goofy acrobatic display with
pointed lightning bolt ends up until
they are caught one goofy looking bolt
here by russell crowe at his side are
two goddesses perhaps hera an aphrodite
or maybe one of his many mistresses
because this is zeus it is a perfect
ruin lives across the world all our
other gods are plotting it looks like
the stands are arranged in boxes with
one larger brightly colored god or
goddess in the center and then they're
minions or sub-deities surrounding them
i assume among these are going to be
here and thor ragnarok is another past
champion of sakhar and most likely
hercules zeus's son a major rival to
thor in the comics who has a ton of arcs
let's get hercules in this movie please
you know i was thinking about it you
might be better at knowing this than me
what mythology is like icarus from and
stuff oh boy
rome is it's either greek or roman and
i'm not actually very good at keeping
them together are they part of the same
mythology as where zeus is from and
hercules and all that i'm not going to
keep them together either yeah it's like
zeus and hercules hades and things like
that like those are all greek as far as
i understand it rome's also got a lot of
their gods from the greeks i feel like
icarus is a greek myth but i couldn't be
certain right now but in the turtles
they said that that was made up right
like olympus and all that yeah yeah i
remember the actual words here athena
and and like that was all just some made
up thing but then this is going to say
that no that stuff really does exist
yeah so now is there like a gods
multiverse like is fina just an athena
variant of some kind or is there a hole
in how the mythology are exciting i
wonder if this one is going to connect
more to eternals than a lot of us
realize this all does look a bit cheesy
but i think that's the point because
we're probably going to see this place
just get wrecked by gore in the opening
act like i'm sorry if you loved zeus and
the other greek gods in the marvel
comics i'll just say don't get too
attached because taiko tt is the same
director who killed the warrior three
with a flick of hella's wrist thor and
cork high five as the text of this
section reads not every god has a plan
which reflects thor's aimless
post-avenger life now but also hearkens
to gore's biggest criticism of the gods
of the marvel universe they have no plan
they let horrible things happen they
cast judgment without explaining the
rules by the end of this film i think we
will find ourselves echoing the words of
nick fury in the comics who whispered to
thor to make him drop mule near gore was
right the one sign of gore's violence in
this trailer at least the corpse of
falagar the behemoth this image taken
directly from jason aaron's godbutcher
storyline artwork by assad ribbik and
thor god of thunder number three when
thor is investigating the deity figures
whom gore has killed even the trickle
blood coming out of falagar's nostrils
is exactly the same i don't think we've
ever seen a frame of the mcu so
perfectly naturally
and i really can't blame them
the only difference is that cork now
joins thor on that boulder so now thor
has someone to explain the terrifying
significance of falagar's death in that
comic panel door explains how falagar
was the patron god of the galactic
frontier who wrestled black holes just
for fun we can also imagine now for all
the ground level people on a planet and
a neighboring star system just for some
[ __ ] to punt his black hole into your
backyard would kill trillions of life
forms then a new shot of new asgard
maybe that's when rocket and smart hulk
approached the town and end game on that
winding road now the port has filled
with several cruise liners including one
with the face of volksdag member of the
warriors three abruptly killed off a van
marks new asgard
drives down that road with a logo that
features mjolnir on it now it looks like
this movie that there's going to be a
mound in this tourism destination that
displays the broken pieces of mjolnir as
a key attraction the earth dug out
around it making a kind of pedestal
since people might not be able to move
the uru shards kind of like how
disneyland has a sword and a stone and
that will be where jane foster is
empowered as the pieces come back
together oh
so that must be where because they're
going to do that play joke thing carry
it over from ragnarok yeah matt damon's
supposed to come back for it so i
imagine that they're going to be redoing
that there as part of their tourist
attraction and then the tour becomes
reality
[Music]
monetize asgard
valkyrie now sits at the head of an
international summit the sign of the
corner reads renewable energy conference
with art looking like a series of
waterfalls that pour into each other
maybe showing how the asgardians and the
olympians recycle water through their
infinity pool water systems that seem
impossible but probably work on some
kind of asgardian magic currently i draw
electricity the united states is
standing because that's what we do here
we stand so i wonder if he hasn't
already in science magic that empowers
their boats and everything else in their
lives has become a pretty game-changing
energy resource on earth which would
complicate things on oil dependent
countries like the us that needs to
protect call jobs and fracking but i
also like how at this table of
international power players seated in
the guest of honors of valkyrie's left
is new zealand i am pretty sure this is
at taiwan tv's insistence
going home an international news ticker
read political turmoil in new asgard
this could be what that was referring to
god i love how the connection
that's so cool
armor these could be the new iron
hurrier of new asgard on earth remember
those are the guards that protected
asgard now they got a new terran to take
on their gear now valkyrie meanwhile
looks bored on her throne an office
chair with asgardian printing along the
back she's chewing food on some skewer
and above her is a sigil which i assume
will be her variant of odin's symbol
maybe turn upside down or something like
that now to the left meek is there
wearing a business suit prepping a drink
for valkyrie cocktails and dreams baby
but notice how valkyrie is sitting right
between two doors hair and dom for the
men in the women's restrooms but right
in the middle it's just some fun framing
reflecting now valkyrie is really a
character who defies gender norms then
another shot of olympus with a huge zeus
well done on that walkway is cork and
thor and then another red caped figure i
assume jane foster you'll know the
statues on the left and the right she's
a little taller on the left maybe
aphrodite on the right that could be
artemis goddess of the hunt good cat
mike i don't know how you do that man
it's like playing where's waldo
sometimes yeah we got a better shot of
the guardians here quill drags goddamn
rocket and groot and mantis has this
interesting chip on her forehead now
which are connected to her antennae
perhaps a way of amplifying her
emotional sensing abilities it's a space
station it's so hard to make will love
him because all the other people he
loves in his life are dead when you
think about it he refuses to break eye
contact just like how he stared peter
directly in the eyes on the benatar at
the end of end game and you can see now
in the close-up that thor has regrown
his braid that he used to have in the
earlier movies before his head was
shaved in ragnarok and before he let
himself go and in-game i love how the
title logo has this metallic look to it
like an 80s rock band just metal pieces
sliding into place in a diamond shape to
form the o which also reflects the
angular text of norse rooms then on to
the last clamp the last clip oh baby so
the reforged mjolnir flies into the hand
of jane foster with natalie portman
returning after throw the dark world in
an adaptation of jason aaron's mighty
thor run that follows jane as a cancer
patient who wields mjolnir after the
case of gore made thor want to drop the
hammer considering himself unworthy now
powering up in a lady thor allows jane
to escape her sickness but whenever she
returns to normal her chemo is reset
setting up this fascinating and tragic
storyline for the character now how did
this happen well the movie's official
description says jane foster who to
thor's surprise inexplicably wields his
magic hammer mjolnir as the mighty thor
that suggests that whatever caused the
samer to reforge was some mysterious
magic that thor is not familiar with now
it's been implied that infinity stones
left cosmic radiation coursing through
the universe and in the case of gene
foster reality stone by the reality
stone ether that radiation could have
been the cause of her cancer as well as
what now triggers the hammer to
reassemble it's also possible that the
multiverse could have caused this
reassembly in some way like she comes
from another universe or the hammer her
arms are so big i know oh i love taylor
after doctor strange's multiverse
madness comes out but for the better
feeling that the hammers return will
have an in-universe answer like either
residual reality stone radiation or some
hidden will and testament clause from
friga or odin that includes jane foster
in that worthiness charm like whoever
wields the sam if he be worthy shall
possess the powers of thor also
underclaws uh whoever that current
bearer uh loves the most can can also
wield
where did the shot destroy the hammer in
ragnarok the cracks of mjolnir are now
spread apart with bigger chunks but
notice how the golden end is facing
upward now i think we're looking at the
other side of it i just like this one
that would be bigger than a more
capillary splintered look because now
from a distance you can still make out
the individual cracks of that hammer
this reveal of natalie portman as lady
thor works really well better than i
thought it would and honestly marvel
studios really needed this to work and
they totally pulled it off but they used
a few interesting visual tricks to do it
now yes jane is definitely beefed up
here i'm sure natalie portman put on
quite a bit of muscle but i wouldn't be
surprised if they did that classic tom
holland muscle enhancement there but she
does need to be beefed up yet the focus
of the shot is not on her muscle
definition her shoulders her traps her
neck forearms they're all covered they
also cover her face with the helmet all
to avoid that uncanny valley effect
where we might see natalie portman's
iconic face but on a different body
which would just kind of freak us out
instead
a striking unusual image to see it put
together again and that is what guides
us into the shot and then we move
directly from mjolnir to jane's eyes
which are locked directly on us see
there is a narrative to this reveal as
opposed to just barfing in a visual
effect in a trailer and we get to pull
it apart there's a story here what it's
interesting to me about that i feel like
i actually wonder if it's just gonna be
a trailer shot or if they're slicing
together from a different scene because
in that moment looks like she's getting
ready to fight thor like why would she
be posing that way upon seeing thor for
the first time yeah yeah yeah why would
she need to do like i'm gonna hold until
you acknowledge me kind of pose or
something yeah it almost like as much as
they don't like to show stuff beyond the
first act it feels as an image more like
you know it's about to go down and i'm
here now kind of thing yeah yeah now
behind both jane and thor it looks like
the town of new asgard is being attacked
by these weird-looking dark tentacled
creatures and then to the left behind
jane whatever this is is flashing some
sharp teeth gore's weapons so she's
posing for that
created by the symbiote deity of no and
we did see in spider-man no way home
that a piece of venom is left in the
boundary of the mcu so could we be
looking at some kind of venom creature
attacking new asgard i don't know i
don't think venom can appear in an mcu
movie without it being a sony
co-production the way spider-man no way
home was so i don't know if they'll keep
that symbiote backstory but if you think
about it the way that dane whitman's
sword the ebony blade also had a black
shape-shifting essence to it when he
reached out to it that could be the same
way gore's blade works making it a kind
of poison not a venom a poison that
rocks a target from the inside out that
could be how we got that chained up
skeleton it could be a poison that
thematically parallels the way cancer
attacks the body
jane's conflict with gore super
important and super symbolic for her in
this movie support us by checking out
our merch options with our moonlight
inspired the moon guide shirt and new
rockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos following
rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
good breakdown that was an a plus
breakdown only only eric voss can make
20 minutes out of 90 90 seconds
yeah and make it not feel like filler at
all
i'm sure he hadn't even cut out more
than that that was great guys subscribe
to new rockstars we haven't done so
already i know more about this movie
than i ever expected to thank you eric
voss thank you all of new rockstars team
before we go to a patreon
anissa i talked to you the other day
and it looks like you're pretty serious
about taking a trip to southern
california yeah and uh you were telling
me some locations that you were thinking
of staying at and i gotta tell you man
i'm excited for when you come
because
john will greet you take over i am going
to greet you with the airport i want to
let you do anything you're hanging with
me and me only and i'm not letting you
out of my sight all right we're gonna
eat together we're gonna drive places
together and sit in traffic and make
awkward conversation together and then
we're gonna go to every theme park in
the southern california area in one day
you're gonna get really tired of hanging
out with me but you're not allowed to
stop because we got time to make up for
anissa plus
gas station tour of the greater los
angeles area am i right
you're gonna love it it's gonna be the
best birthday you're gonna wish that
there were no more birthdays to come
you're
you're gonna have time for the channel
though
yeah
it's debatable
[Music]